[Musique]
elle avait des bains gaschard ac doit
d'état de bracelets autour des poignets
et puis elle chantait avec une voix qui
sitôt monge là
elle avait des yeux des yeux de pales
qui fascinait qui fascinait y avait la
balle de son visage pâle de femme fatale
qui fut fatale de femme fatale qui fut
atteint on s'est connus on s'est
reconnus on s'est perdus on cerbère du
but on s'est retrouvés on s'est
réchauffée cuisant s'est séparé
chacun pour soi est reparti dans
tourbillon de la vie je les remets un
soir aïe aïe aïe ça fait déjà un fameux
bail ça m'est déjà un fameux bain
au son des bandes jour je l'ait reconnu
ce curieux sourire qui m'avait tant plu
ça voici fatale son beau visage pâle
mais mur plus que jamais je me suis
saoul et en l'écoutant l'alcool fait
oublier le temps je me suis rêver
c'est un baiser sur mon front blanc des
baisers sur mon front bruno en c'est
connu on s'est reconnus
on s'est perdus ont certes perdu on
s'est retrouvés on s'est réchauffé puis
on s'est séparés chacun pour soi est
reparti dans to be ont bien
je n'ai revu un soir à la halle à elle
est retombée dans mes bras elle est
retombée dans mes bras quand on s'est
connu quand on s'est reconnus pour quoi
se perdre de vue ce re perdre de vue
quand on s'est retrouvé quand on s'est
réchauffé pourquoi se séparer
alors tous deux en l'air parti dans tout
billion de la vie
on a continué à tourner pour les deux
ans là c'est tous les ans lassé tous les
deux ans
[Musique]